[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine der Fragen die uns von euch häufig
unter unseren Videos gestellt wird
lautet wie kommt ihr eigentlich auf die
Themen für eure Videos nun im heutigen
Video geht es um ein Thema das
eigentlich schon ein knappes Jahr durch
die gegengeistert aber kaum jemand hat
bemerkt wie erstaunlich es eigentlich
ist und welches Potenzial letztendlich
in ihm steckt seht euch mal diese
Nachricht an der tschetschenische Joker
RAM Sam Cardio schließt sich den
russischen Kriegseinsatz an die
demokratischen Kriegsherren Kräfte waren
von Anfang an fester Bestandteil der
Kriegsrede des Krems die eigentliche
Nachricht ist in diesem Fall das ist
diese Geschichte überhaupt in die
Nachrichten geschafft hat betrachtet ist
doch mal so Tschetschenien ist eine
Region der Russischen Föderation wenn
Russland in ein Land ein marschiert
werden natürlich tschetschenische
Truppen dabei sein genauso wie Truppen
aus jeder anderen Region
[Musik]
aber in diesem Fall geht es um
ramsamkeit darauf und dieser verfügt
offensichtlich nicht nur über einen noch
größere narzisstische
Persönlichkeitsstörung als Putin sondern
auch über eine eigene Armee eine Armee
mit einem hohen Maß an Unabhängigkeit
und nach Schätzungen denn sichere Zahlen
haben wir leider nicht etwa 12.000
Soldaten die als besonders grausam
bekannt sind mit anderen Worten
innerhalb Russlands gibt es eine Region
die ihre eigene Armee hat deren
Loyalität nicht vorrangig den
Präsidenten des Landes Geld zugleich
wird diese Armee jedoch zum Teil mit
Geldern aus dem gremmen direkt
finanziert und ich ahne was einige von
euch jetzt denken werden privat Armeen
und regionale Milizen hat es schon immer
gegeben doch aus Russland bzw Ukraine
Krieg hört man bei diesem Thema viel
mehr von der privaten sollte Truppe
Wagner als von Kathi rausstreut macht
und ja da habt ihr Recht die
wagnertruppe des Unternehmers und Putin
geträumen jetzt gehen ist aber ein ganz
Russland betreffendes Phänomen während
eine bestimmte Religion verträgt das
Problem ist das
nicht irgendein Region ist
[Musik]
in den letzten drei Jahrzehnten führte
die Provinz 2 blutige
Unabhängigkeitskriege gegen Russland
wenn es eine interessante Region in der
gesamten russischen Föderation gibt dann
ist es sicherlich Tschetschenien man
könnte sogar sagen dass sie einen ganz
besonderen Platz innerhalb des
russischen Staates einnimmt viele nehmen
das aus dem Moskau verbreitete Bild für
selbstverständlich das Russland ein
unteilbares Land sei und alle seine
Bürger von St Petersburg bis dort stolze
Kinder von Mütter Russland aber die
Wahrheit ist selten so einfach und es
gibt gerade in einem so großen Staat wie
der Russischen Föderation natürlich
Landesteile die historisch ethnisch und
kulturelle längst nicht so fest
angeboten und integriert sein wie die
russischen Kern Lande historisch handelt
es sich schlicht um einfach um Kolonien
und Tschetschenien ist einer davon
schließlich kann man Russland als das
letzte große europäische Kolonialreich
betrachten das noch nicht völlig
auseinandergefallen ist aber diesen
Verzug in punkto Dekolonialisierung
scheint es gerade ungewollt nachzuholen
und spielt dabei eine ganz besondere
Rolle die Frage ist also inwieweit
können wir davon sprechen dass paderov
eine Armee hat die mit der russischen
vergleichbar ist und wie weit geht
eigentlich die tschetschenische
Loyalität gegenüber dem Rest Russlands
heute werden wir natürlich all diese
Fragen beantworten und euch dabei so oft
darum gebeten werden als Bonus noch eine
aktuelle Lageeinschätzung zum
Kriegsverlauf geben lasst uns aber
vorher noch einen kurzen Werbehinweis
unseres tollen Sponsors zur Frage
einspielen und danach sofort ungestört
fortfahren können denn surfshark ist ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keinerlei
verbindungsdatenmittlung natürlich kann
ein wäscheteils nett vor allem Gefahren
schützen die jetzt lauern man muss nach
wie vor unsichtbar lassen und wissen was
man tut aber es stellt hier für ein
Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen
darf zum einen erschwert ist in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktionen im Netz nachzuverfolgen
und abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheit könnt ihr so eure Anonymität
im Netz erhöhen z.B mit dem integrierten
Team wird das alle unerwünschten Cookies
und pop-blockt weiter Vorteile eines VPN
ist was ihr so tun könnt als während ihr
an einem anderen Ort so könnte zum Sport
Website und Internetdienste zugreifen
die dem Land in die wir gerade seid
nicht verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt die Zensur und
geoblocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes die ihre Inhalte nur in den USA
Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internetfernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit surfshark kein Problem aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles denn mit
nur einem surfshark und dann könnt ihr
wirklich alle eure Endgeräte in VPN
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt ihr
sonst auch noch ein Rabatt in Höhe von
83% und deine ersten 3 Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts besorgt haben auch
gleichzeitig uns finanzielle unter die
Arme das könnte übrigens auch direkt mit
Hilfe des Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
haben wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung bei den damit hättet ihr
uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu liefern so und nun ab
in den Kaukasus wo wir einen schnellen
Blick in die Geschichte der Teenies
werden um den Antworten auf unsere
Fragen auf die Spur zu kommen
das Sizilien des Kaukasus
es mag euch überraschen aber die
Geschichte dieser Region hat nur sehr
wenig mit der Russlands gemeint während
die mehrheitsregion in Russland das
orthodoxe Christentum ist sind die
Tschechien überwiegend Muslime und nicht
nur das sie haben auch ihre eigene
Sprache die bis 1920 in arabischen
Schriftzeichen geschrieben wurde das ist
aber nicht nur in dieser Region so in
der Russischen Föderation geht es über
20 sogenannte Republiken das sind
Regionen die einen besonderen Status in
haben weil sie ihre eigene Kultur
Sprache oder sogar Geschichte besitzen
und im Falle der Tschechien handelt es
sich um eines der ältesten Völker des
Kaukasus im Laufe ihrer Geschichte
würden sie zwar vom terroristischen
Russland erobert aber auch von anderen
reichen die den Mongolen nachdem sie
über die Jahrhunderte Teil von vielen
verschiedenen Reichen gewesen waren
entwickelten die verschiedenen
schließlich ihre eigenen Institutionen
die den jeweiligen eroberan fremd waren
wir sprechen hier bei von Netzwerken von
Familien Clans die den ähneln was ja
hunderte lang die sizilianische Mafia
war mit anderen Worten egal wie oft die
Zahlen im 19 Jahrhundert in
Tschetschenien einmarschierten die Leute
gegen den Patriarchen ihres clansstreu
ergeben und nicht irgendeinem aus Moskau
eingesetzten Beamten im Jahr 1917
versuchten mehrere dieser Clans einen
souveränen und unabhängigen Staat zu
gründen die bergrepublik im Nordkaukasus
sie wurden sogar von mehreren
internationalen Akteuren anerkannt aber
schnell von russischen Truppen
zerschlagen 1921 wurde hier bereits eine
sowjetische gebirgsrepublik ausgerufen
zu der auch Tschetschenien gehört
und was glaubt ihr was damals passiert
ist nun egal wie sehr der Kreml
versuchte die Region zu russifizieren
die Tschechien hielten ihren Clan
ältesten die Treue daran änderten auch
die Massen Deportation des Darlehen
ihrer wenig von 1944 bis 57 waren und
besonders nach Zentralasien verbannt
worden die ist Verwirrung war findet vor
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs mit den
Nazis kollaboriert zu haben und so
kommen wir schließlich bis ins Jahr 1991
den ja indem wir alle wissen die
udssr-in in diesem Jahr wurden alle 15
VW Republiken zu unabhängigen Staaten
Russland die Ukraine kasachstanweisung
für Orient die drei waldischen Staaten
und so weiter und so fort weniger Glück
hatten aber jede Gebiete und
Völkerschaften die bis Datum nicht den
Status eines Torwart Republik gehabt
hatten sondern nur den einer autonomen
sowie Republik als Teilgebiet eine diese
15 VW Republiken sowohl in den neuen
Hauptstädten als auch im westlichen
Ausland war man der Meinung dass diesen
natriumpubliken keine unabhäng
Möglichkeit zustünde natürlich gab es
einige Völker die die Gelegenheit denn
noch beim Shop ergriffen und dies
dennoch durchsetzen wollten so liefen
die Tschetschenen nachdem sie sich noch
schnell von ihren ungeliebten
Mitbewohnern in der Sowjetrepublik den
guschen getrennt hatten in Grosny ihrer
eigenen Republik aus sie erklärten 1991
die tschetschenische Republik experience
zu einem unabhängigen Staat und an
dieser Stelle kommt der große
Unterschied die 15 nachfolgestanden
wurden ohne größere Probleme unabhängig
weltweit anerkannt und sie ließen sich
gegenseitig weitgehend in Frieden nun ja
mit Ausnahme also bei Chance und Armee
ist die sich einen Krieg um bergabach
lieferten denn in vielen Fällen wurden
ihre neuen Regierungen von denselben
Politikern aus das Vorbild ihrer geführt
die schon vorher die Zügel in der Hand
hatten es gab ein paar kosmetische
Veränderungen aber in wesentlichen
handelte es sich um die selben Leute der
falsche Schienen ist leider ganz anders
seine russland hat die Unabhängigkeit
nicht akzeptiert dafür gibt es eine
Menge Gründe und einer davon war Erdöl
ja in der Region gibt es Ölvorkommen
aber es gibt auch eine ganze Menge
komplexer politischer Gründe auf die wir
nicht eingehen werden weil dieses Video
sonst drei Stunden dauern würde
die Kurzfassung ist das Russland 1994
inchingen einmarschierte um dieser
paratisten zu neutralisieren und damit
den ersten Krieg gegangen zunächst sah
alles so aus als würde die Invasion ein
militärisches Kinderspiel für die
russische Armee werden man muss sich das
so vorstellen eine arme kleiner Region
gegen einen militärisches Schwergewicht
im Jahr 1994 hatte nur etwa 1,3
Millionen Einwohner und auf der anderen
Seite stand Russland das war durch den
Kollaps das wird geschwächt war aber
immer noch eine bedeutende Militär macht
darstellte der erste chineskrieg war für
Moskau jedoch ein großer misser Erfolg
so sehr dass sie 1996 einen
Waffenstillstand unterzeichneten und
sich zurückziehen mussten und ihr würde
denken dass dies einen eingefrorenen
Konflikt bedeutet oder nur nein
tatsächlich begann hier der wahre
Albtraum für Russland im Jahr 1999
vielen tschechische Rebellen die von
extremistischen muslimischen Geistlichen
radikalisiert wurden in die benachbarte
Region ein die Republik da gestern ihr
Ziel war ein vereinigtes muslimisches
Kaukasus califikat es handelt sich also
nicht mehr nur um eine einzige
abtrünnige Region sondern auch um eine
von dort ausgehende Bedrohung für die
angrenzenden Gebiete der Russischen
Föderation und zumindest entstand im
September 99 dieses Bild auch das einer
Bedrohung für das Leben aller Russen
selbst wenn sie friedlich weit ab vom
Kaukasus lebten vier Wohnblöcke zwei in
Moskau und zweiten Süden Russlands
wurden bei Anschlägen in die Luft
gesprengt es gab 300 Tote die Urheber
sollen tschetschenische Terrassen
gewesen sein so lautet zumindest das
offizielle narratives inzwischen gibt es
jedoch viele Berichte und Recherchen die
naheliegen das zumindest die beiden
Moskau Anschläge das Werk des FSB waren
aber warum in aller Welt sollte eine
staatliche Organisation so etwas tun
hunderte von eigenen Bürgern im Schlaf
in die Luft sprenge nun ja eine
klassische Flag Operation eben und wenn
man dringend einen wirklich überzeugend
aus dem Grund braucht um die aufsässigen
radikalislamischen Kämpfer mit massiver
Gewalt erkämpfen zu können nicht nur in
der Gegenden
und außerdem kein Problem damit hat über
die leichten Hunderter unschuldiger zu
gehen dann noch mal ein solches Vorgehen
für einen genialen Plan halten dabei
stellt sich aber noch die Frage wer war
es eigentlich der da im Herbst 99 den
Krieg gegen die tschetschenischen
Terroristen ausrief nein es war nicht
der damalige Präsident baresien das
macht er sein erst ganz frisch ins Amt
geholter neuer Ministerpräsident das ist
jener Moment in dem der Mann auf den ihr
sicher schon lange gewartet habt auf der
Bildfläche erscheint es war kein
geringerer als Wladimir Putin tja und
welchen Posten hatte dieser damals noch
ziemlich unbekannte man zu vorher gehabt
haltet euch fest er war Direktor des FSB
gewesen also der Leiter ihn jenes
mächtigen Inlandsgeheimdienstes der
mutmaßlich für die Anschläge
verantwortlich war
[Musik]
wenn du sie nicht schlagen kannst
schließe dich ihnen an
[Musik]
und seitdem waren die Karriere und das
Schicksal Putins mit Tschetschenien eng
verknüpft am 31 Dezember 99 wurde Putin
Präsident der Russischen Föderation vor
ihm lang zwei große Herausforderungen
die traurige Wirtschaftslage zu
verbessern und das Tschetschenien
Problem zu lösen so begann der zweite
chillenkrieg ein Krieg in dem der Kreml
alle seine Ressourcen auf Spiel setzte
und ihr könnt euch sicher schon denken
was das bedeutet es wird geschätzt dass
etwa 15.000 Listen ums Leben haben doch
dies war längst keine regionale Konflikt
mehr tschetschenische Terroristen
sollten dafür dass jede Hose diesen
Krieg zu spüren bekam und glaub mir es
gibt keine Russen der sich nicht an
dieser Ereignisse
erinnert das war 2002 März 700 Geiseln
von den 130 ihr Leben verloren die
meisten von ihnen übrigens deswegen weil
das russische Einsatzkommando sie
rücksichtslos vergasste aber wenn diese
Anschlag nicht ausreicht um euch das
Blut in den Adam gefrieren zu lassen
chemische Touristen im Jahr 2004 alle
moralischen Grenzen gesprengt die Rede
ist von der Geiselnahme in der Schule
von bislan in diesem Fall brach eine
bewaffnete Gruppe in eine Schule ein und
nahm
1181 Geiseln wie euch denken könnt waren
die meisten von ihnen Kinder in diesem
Fall verloren 333 Menschen ihr Leben
wobei wie schon zwei Jahre zuvor im
Moskauer Theater unbestreitbar ein
wesentlicher Teil der Toten aber auch in
die Verantwortung der russischen
Sicherheitskräfte viel mit wenig
zimperlichen Sturm Angriffen auf die
Geiselnehmer das Leben der Geissen nicht
hochachteten diese terror-serie bei der
ist auch zu Explosionen im
Verkehrsflugzeugen und der Moskauer
U-Bahn kam zeigte unbestreitbar eines
der Chichi in Konflikt war eine
nationale Priorität und wie hat Putin
das Problem gelöst hat er den Krieg
militärisch gewonnen nun nein Putin hat
den zweiten Krieg anderweitig gelöst und
zwar mit Geld
[Applaus]
ein Land der Warlords war und beschloss
auf einen zu setzen der die Kontrolle
über das Gebiet übernehmen wird deshalb
unterstützt er einen dieser Kriegsherren
mit all seinen Mitteln Ahmad Kara der
damals auch Mufti von cecilien war also
das muslimische religiöse Oberhaupt im
Land kann die auflag zugleich auch im
Clinch mit den dortigen radikal
islamischen bahariten zugleich sprechen
wir jedoch auch über an dieser
tschetschenischen Clans die KD raus
waren schon immer muslimische
Unabhängigkeitskämpfer aber leider ist
eine Lehrer Geldbeutel auch allmächtiger
Gegner im Jahr 2000 machte Putin diesen
Mann zum verwaltungsgeschäft ganz
Tschechiens 2003 ließ er ihn dort zu
Präsidenten der Republik wählen ein Jahr
später wurde Ahmad wieder von anderen
tschechischen Separatisten die ihn für
ein Verräter hielten ermordet sein
Nachfolger wurde sein Sohn ramsamsam
kann dir auch und ja das ist genau der
kann dir auf den wir alle kennen der
zwischenzeitlich Millionen von verloren
auf Instagram hatte bevor sein Account
gelöscht wurde im Grunde hat Putin die
keine Ross Vater wie Sohn mit Geld und
dann überschüttet und ihnen gesagt
erledige all deine Gegner regieren wie
ist dir gefällt und im Gegenzug verlange
ich nur eines von dir ich will keinen
einzigen Terroranschlag mehr in diesem
Land und genauso endete der zweite Krieg
die Lösung des tschetschenienkonflikts
war also so einfach weil man nur einen
der Kriegsherren mit Gold zu
überschritten brauchte nein natürlich
nicht haltet euch fest denn jetzt kommt
die surrealste Wendung in unserer
Geschichte
Las Vegas Muslim Version
[Musik]
[Applaus]
könnt ihr euch eine Moschee in
Neonfarben vorstellen nun es gibt sie
und sie steht in groß-nieder Hauptstadt
Tschetscheniens schaut euch doch mal an
wie wundervoll sie ausschaut tja so hat
kardi Rauch seine Republik nach den
Krieg wieder aufgebaut und nicht nur das
es gibt zahlreiche Prominente die diesen
Ort besucht haben
happy Birthday für den World Hillary
Swank und Jean-Claude Van Damme unter
Beschuss wegen der berüchtigten Partie
des tschechischen Anführers
angesichtssen würde man meinen dass
dieser Ort so etwas wie das Duba das
Kaukasus sein muss oder ein Ort an dem
das Geld auch Bäumen wächst doch in
Wirklichkeit ist immer noch eine der
ärmsten Regionen Russlands gemessen am
pro
kopfste russische föderationsregion was
wird denn so in Ross kleinen Reich
produziert nun ehrlich gesagt nicht viel
die Wirtschaft der Region befindet sich
praktisch im Mittelalter im Jahr 2021
waren 81 Prozent der Exporte Weizen ja
nicht einmal die Ölfelder der Provinz
reichen aus um die Wirtschaft
anzukurbeln und wie werden dann
eigentlich diese Neon Moscheen bezahlt
nun ganz einfach mit dem Geld das aus
Moskau kommt doch wie ihr euch sicher
vorstellen könnt sind diese staatlichen
Gelder nicht nur für die Neon Moscheen
bestimmt sie dienen auch dazu aufs
eigenen Lebenswandel zu finanzieren und
was glaubt ihr was passiert wenn ein
wollwort mit geldüberschüttet wird nun
zunächst einmal Dinge wie diese Pariser
Mode Debüt von Karl der Ross Tochter ist
ein Schlag ins Gesicht aber das ist nur
der unbedeutendste Teil das wirklich
besorgniserregende daran einen Warlord
mit Geld zu überschritten ist dass
dieser Rubel für Waffen ausgegeben
werden für viele Waffen Essen wird
geschätzt das kann die aus Armee bis zu
12.000 Soldaten umfasst einen
beachtliche Zahlen bedenkt dass sie etwa
der Zahl der russischen Truppen in der
Tschetschenien Region entspricht die
eine russische Armee ist in fünf
militärbezirke unterteilt Westen Süden
Zentrum Osten und Norden Tschetschenien
gehört zum Militärbezirk Süd der über
etwa 80.000 Soldaten verfügt aber wenn
man bedenkt dass er sich über 15
föderationsgebiete erstreckt ist die
tschetschenische Armee im Vergleich zur
russischen Armee in der Region also gar
nicht schlecht aufgestellt mit anderen
Worten die sogenannten Kalli könnte man
zahlenmäßig mit Putins eigenen Truppen
vergleichen und das ist besonders
besorgniserregend wenn man bedenkt dass
Tschetschenien zu einer grausamen
Diktatur geworden ist in der es sogar
Konzentrationslager für Homosexuelle
gibt ja neben ramsamkeit auf kann sogar
ein Vladimir Putin wie ein netter Kerl
wirken im Moment ist gerade darauf zu
100% loyal gegenüber pro Kind
schließlich leben sie in einer Art
Symbiose potient zahlt einfach alle
Rechnungen und kann dir auf hält ihn im
Gegenzug die tschetischen bzw Sachen die
karl ist islamischen Terroristen vom
Hals und die Preisfrage lautet der
Ukraine Krieg dieses macht Gleichgewicht
irgendwie verändert nun genau das werden
wir uns jetzt jetzt ansehen
kadeoffs Video Truppe
wer sind eigentlich diese gefürchteten
cardi auf Leute nun ist handelt sich um
Cudi roff Treue Kämpfer und
Geheimdienstler die als besonders brutal
gelten sie wurden schon mehrfach
beschuldigt keksgefangenen brutal
gefoltert und ermordet zu haben diese
Leute scheren sich wenig um
Menschenrechte den tschetschenischen
Soldaten als eine Ruf als erbarmungslose
und harte Kämpfer voraus tatsächlich
haben sich auch so manche geschehen die
nicht loyaluron stehen sogar der da echt
im sogenannten islamischen Staat
angeschlossen darunter aber
einer der gefürchteten Kommentare der
Terrorgruppe war er wurde 2016 von den
Vereinigten Staaten ausgeschaltet und
Kathi rosskämpfer sind auch Experten im
Häuserkampf die hat sie wahrscheinlich
schon in ihren zahlreichen tiktok Videos
im Ukraine gesehen
[Musik]
ist ein Liebhaber der sozialen Medien er
hatte Millionen von Followern auch
instagram ist seit Account wie gesagt
gelöscht wurde aber jetzt könnt ihr
Videos von tschetschenischen Soldaten
oder Kalli auf selbst auf tiktok finden
und einige Grenzen wirklich ganz absurde
[Musik]
also ich verstehe den Sinn dieses Videos
auch nicht aber die meisten Videos die
Sie Posten sind nicht besonders lustig
ganz im Gegenteil wer alle haben Bilder
von hingerichteten Soldaten Knien den
Gefangenen und noch viel schlimmeren
gesehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ursprünglich er würde 10.000 Soldaten in
die Ukraine schicken und hat kürzlich
behauptet ist deren sogar 20.000 dabei
solle es sich sowohl um Berufssoldaten
als auch umwerflichtige handeln aber
natürlich kommt viele anlüsten dazu ganz
abweichenden Betrachtungen soweit wir
wissen wurden drei tschetschenische
taktische Verbände verlegt das 141
motorisierte ahmadiro spezialregiment
das motorisierte sonderbatterien und das
Boss top Bataillon das Rostock Bataillon
wurde 2008 nach internen Macht kämpfen
mit dem ehemaligen Kommandeur zu liegen
ja mal da jetzt ebenfalls an ehemaliger
chinesisches reparatist fast aufgelöst
auch wenn die genaue Truppenstärke das
ist nicht bekannt ist überhaupt
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr als 4000
Soldaten gesagt hat und es stimmt dass
sie für ihre Grausamkeit bekannt sind
aber sind sie auch wirklich effektiv nun
schauen wir mal kann ich auch sagte das
ist eines seiner Ziele war seine Lenski
direkt zu töten und dass sie in Mario
Paul kieff und in der Gegend von Butcher
am aktivsten waren also dort wo Alter
von Zivilisten nach ihrem Rückflug tot
aufgefunden wurden nun wenn die kardi
rovz tatsächlich so kompetente Soldaten
wären hätten wir wahrscheinlich andere
Ergebnisse gesehen denn weder vor Kiew
noch in mariopol hat sich Russland gut
geschlagen im Kampf haben sie sich als
ebenbürtig mit einem
durchschnittssoldaten erwiesen auch kann
die rosmissionen gleich zu Beginn der
Invasion selenski zu liquidieren alles
andere als erfolgreich
[Musik]
am 26 februar finden ukrainische
Streitkräfte eine tschetschenische
Gruppe ab die tatsächlich den Patienten
ermorden sollte und liquidierten sie am
4 März namens ukrainische Truppen eine
Einheit entschieden gefangen und
beschlagnahmen und ihre Waffen und ein
Kampffahrzeug und 40 Tage nach Beginn
der Invasion zerstörten die Ukraine noch
ein tschechischen Konsole mit 56
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen all diese
militärischen brachten kann die rosshof
in Gefahr Ukraine verspotten seine
Streit macht inzwischen als die tiktok
Truppe die nur beim Drehen kriegsvideos
besonderen schneit und Einsatz beweist
kardi Roxette hat im Gegenzug scharfe
Kritik an der russischen Militärführung
und anders Situation geübt wenn sich
heute und morgen nichts an der
Durchführung der militärischen Spezial
Operation ändert bin ich gezwungen mich
an die Führung des Landes das
Verteidigungsministerium zu verwenden um
Ihnen die Situation vor Ort zu erklären
und das ist noch nicht alles viele
Medien behaupten dass Kardio auf seine
besten Leute zum eigenen Schutz in
Tschechien zurückgelassen und eben nicht
in die Ukraine geschickt hat es dürfte
also klar sein dass die karibowski im
Moment Putin eher in den Massenmedien
ihre Loyalität beweisen als auf dem
Schlachtfeld
[Musik]
der Grund sie sind überhaupt nicht für
den Kampf auch dem Schlachtfeld
ausgebildet sondern eher eine Art
Polizeitruppe und Palastgarten und sie
mögen sehr sadistisch sein gegen eine
reguläre moderne Truppe haben sie doch
kaum eine Chance und so kampfstark und
effektiv wie sie sich gerne Brüsten sind
sie schon gar nicht trotzdem stellt sich
eine Frage was wenn die keine ruft sie
keine Gefahr für die Ukraine darstellen
sondern eher für Pute nun diesen kleinen
potenziell Problem werden denn nun auf
den Zahn fühlen aufgepasst
latent abtrünnig
ein weiteres Problem ist dass die
tschetschenischen Kommandeure und der
russische Geheimnis nur schlecht
zusammenarbeiten gerade weil sie ihre
eigenen Wege gehen seht euch mal diese
Nachricht an es gibt anhaltende
Streitigkeiten zwischen
tschetschenischen Kommandeuren und dem
russischen Geheimdienst Truppen betonen
dass sie unter dem Kommando von Kalium
stehen nicht unter dem der russischen
Militär Hierarchie außerdem haben die
Tschechien im Gegensatz zu den Russen
Smartphones dabei mit denen Sie alles
aufzeichnen und in die sozialen Medien
hochladen können wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnt ist das ein großes Geschenk für
den ukrainischen Geheimdienst zudem
sprechen Sie unter Umgebung der direkten
viele Putins ganz offen von einem Krieg
gegen die Ukraine und nicht von einer
militärischen spezialoperation
die Loyalität ist also nicht
selbstverständlich die darauf Ziele
betrachten Putins Regime als Futtertrog
mit anderen Worten wenn das Geld
ausbleibt geht wahrscheinlich auch die
Loyalität Flöten außerdem sind viele der
tschetschenischen Truppen ehemalige
separatistenkämpfer die aufgrund der
Umstände die Seiten gewechselt haben
viele von ihnen haben durch russisches
militärfamilienmitglieder verloren oder
haben Verwandte die bis heute vermisst
werden es gibt Gerüchte dass kardiograph
bereits einige seiner Soldaten abgezogen
hat und im Juli verwunderte er viele in
Russland mit seiner Forderungen
Russlands Armee möge doch in den Bergen
Tschetscheniens eine luftabwehrbasis
errichten wozu eine luftabwehrbasis vor
wem soll sie Tschetschenien schützen
etwa vor der Ukraine vorgeorgien oder
kavirus radikal islamischen
Gegenspielern die haben doch überhaupt
keine Luftwaffe nun eine deutliche
Antwort darauf gab die Julia latinina
von der russischen exil-zeitung nur weil
er gazzeta Foppa ich sehe nur einen
wirklichen Nutzen für diese Luftabwehr
Schutz vor russischen Raketen und
Flugzeugen in einem Bürgerkrieg der auf
dem Kollaps des ukrainischen Abenteuers
und die Niederlage Putins folgen könnte
dieser Vorschlag zeigt deutlich dass
Karl der oft über die Perspektiven des
Regimes nachdenkt und wor ob er sich
vorbereitet aber unterstützen wir nicht
alle Tschetschenen Putin nun nein alle
waren es nie und immer weniger von ihnen
sind zu Moskau loyal tatsächlich hat im
Laufe des Krieges Inter Ukraine dort
auch die Präsenz von gegen Russland
kämpfenden Tschechien zugenommen die
Tschetschenen die sich der Ukraine
angeschlossen haben gehören
hauptsächlich zwei Bataillonen an
benannt nach Joker du dajew und
scheichmann Schuhe diese beiden
Bataillonen bestehen größtenteils aus
der transien Kriege und vor einem
Tschechien Georg und Freiwillige aus
Aserbaidschan die meisten Freiwilligen
sind scharfe Kritiker des krematorischen
Regimes von carreros
separatistenregierung kündigte seine
Bereitschaft an freiwillige zu
Unterstützung der Ukraine zu entsenden
für selbst wird es immer schwieriger
Freiwillige für seine Sache Entchen ist
Reproduktion wo die Menschen ist
offenbar alt sind von Putin in einem
schlecht laufenden Krieg verheizt zu
werden wie wir gesehen haben kämpft für
Russland eine mit heißer Nadel
zusammengestoppelte Armee sie besteht
aus Resten aufgeriebene reguläre
Einheiten einer permobil-machung
zwangsrekrutierten Leidenschaft
Separatisten Armeen aus dem Don Bass der
mit Gefängnisinsassen aufgestockten
Söldnertruppe von prigorien und eben
diesen unsicheren patronisten den
kardios Ziel es handelt sich also um
alles andere als einen einheitlichen
Block aus Stahl wie Putin es vorgibt der
Krieg in der Ukraine könnte nun der
Zünder für die dicken der Zeitraum sein
die hausmannseinheit als Staat droht
erst recht wenn es sich weiter so
entwickelt wie im Herbst als Russland
eine Niederlage nach der anderen
kassierte ich meine eines ist klar Putin
hofft darauf dass ihr früher genügend
Kräfte aus seiner ersten
mobilisierungsfälle ausreichend
ausgebildet sind um eine neue Offensive
zu starten die einen solchen Namen auch
verdienen würde und er will dann auch
wohl mit einer zweiten mobil machen sein
zynisches Fleisch Fließband am Laufen
halten doch die Ukraine und ihre
Verbündeten werden dem nicht tatenlos
zusehen und sie tun dies auch jetzt
nicht im Gegenteil sie wollen ihm einen
gehörigen Strich durch die Rechnung
machen
[Musik]
denn auch über die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte im Dezember und Anfang
Januar keine signifikanten
Geländegewinne erzielen konnten wenn man
die Zahl der russischen Verluste
analysiert erkennt man dass die
Prognosen aus unserem Video darüber
warum Russland vor dem Winterkrieg in
der Ukraine zittert weitestgehend
eintreten also was genau sagen uns die
Zahlen nun auch eine etwas modifizierte
Art und Weise wiederholt sich das
Szenario aus dem Sommer und dem Herbst
es geht um die ukrainische Kampagne des
Todes durch tausend Schnitte gegen
munitions- und Treibstoff der Post und
Position der russischen
Befehlsstrukturen was jedoch neu ist er
Beschuss durch präzisionsartillerie
wurde nun systematisch auf russische
Personal Konzentration ausgeweitet und
die Ergebnisse sind beeindruckend seit
dem 29 Dezember gibt die Ukraine an pro
Tag 700 russische Soldaten außer Gefecht
zu setzen zum Vergleich was soll Daten
angeht er leiden die Russen nun
wesentlich stärker Verluste als im
Sommer und das obwohl die Intensität der
Kampfhandlungen an der Front eigentlich
abgenommen hat aber lasst uns doch noch
mal etwas genauer unter die Lupe nehmen
denn das wirklich Interessante an den
Zahlen ist die Tatsache dass die hohen
Verluste nur das Personal betreffen
nicht so sehr dass Material was also ist
da los nun aus zwei Gründen verloren die
Russen im Dezember weniger als ein
Drittel der Panzer und sogar nur ein
Sechstel der gepanzerten Fahrzeuge
gegenüber September erstens natürlich
weil das Wetter und die verschlammten
Böden ihren Einsatz sowieso sinnlos
machen zweitens aber auch aus dem Grund
weil ihnen die Fahrzeuge wahrscheinlich
einfach langsam ausgehen im Gegensatz
dazu haben sie jedoch eine große Menge
schlecht ausgebildeter und ausgerüsteter
neuen mobilisierter Soldaten der
sogenannten Mobbing als Kanonenfutter an
die Front geworfen
und diese tragen nun nicht nur die
todesstatistiken in die Höhe sondern
Hennen sogar die administrative und
logistische Operationsfähigkeit der
gesamten russischen Streitkräfte es
sieht alles danach aus als ob 8 bis 13
frisch mobilisierte russische Infanterie
bataillonskampfgruppen in den letzten
Wochen zerschlagen worden und das alles
relative Chaos das dadurch entstand die
gesamte frontgeschwächt hat erinnert ihr
euch noch als wir in unserem
winterkriegsvideo erwähnt haben dass die
mobics kaum geeignete Winterkleidung
bekommen diese Praxis hat dazu geführt
dass die mobis ständig Zuflucht vor
Kälte suchen müssen damit sie überhaupt
fit genug sind um irgendwie geeignet
antwortest davon eingesetzt zu werden
und auf eines könnt ihr Gift nehmen
diese armen Schlucker sind genau
diejenigen welche die russische Armee
Führung an vorderster Front verheißen
will bevor es die besser ausgebildeten
Kräfte nachschickt und die ukrainische
Artillerie konzentriert sich nun eben
auf die Achillesferse dieser Strategie
sie bombardiert gezielt die warmen
Unterschriften und die russischen
Führungsstrukturen sind nur noch damit
beschäftigt diese taktischen
reservegruppen in den gesetzten Gebieten
ständig zu verschieben aufzulösen oder
zuerst setzen diese personalintensiven
logistikoperationen führen jedoch zu
einer Menge russischen Funkverkehrs auch
durch die Handys das Soldaten und diesen
können die ukraelischen Speer wiederum
nutzen um neue Ziele zu finden ein
Teufelskreis und zugleich ein Cut und
Mausspiel die systematische Zerstörung
der mobil Unterkünfte hat dazu geführt
dass Russland einfach keine Orte mehr
hat an denen es seine reservebataione
vor der keltische schützen kann bevor
die arktische Kaltfront kommt denn all
diese vermöbungsangriffe erfüllten
rechtzeitig bevor der Boden hat genug
für groß angelegte mobile
panzeroperation gefriert von den die
Ukraine den ganzen Dezember
übergesprochen hat und passen Tier zu
kocht nun rein zufällig die Meldung dass
ein großes Tabu gebrochen wird ihr
Lieferung von Panzern an die Ukraine
westliche Panzer als Schlüssel zum
Durchbruch auf dem ukrainischen
Schlachtfeld Präsident erklärte am
Mittwoch das Paris der Ukraine leichte
vom Typ am X10 RC aus französischer
Produktion übergeben wird der amx-10 ist
ein 25 Tonnen schwerer aufklärungspanzer
mit räderfahrwerk der mit einer 105 mm
Kanone bewaffnet ist und während des
Kalten Krieges entwickelt wurde um sich
schnell zu bewegen und potenzielle
Durchbrüche in den feindlichen Linien
auszunutzen
schwere Waffen für Kiew Bundesregierung
liefert Ukraine Marder Panzer und
patricksystem Deutschland liefert der
Ukraine Marder Panzer und ein Patrick
Raketenabwehrsystem die USA werden der
Regierung in Kiew zu dem leichte
brändlegeschützen Panzer und wie
angedacht Patrick System liefern der
Marder gilt nicht als Kampfpanzer kann
mit seiner Maschinen Kanone und mit
Panzerabwehrraketen ausgestattet aber
gegnerische
Fahrzeuge bekämpfen und auch wenn es
sich vorerst nur um leichte Panzer die
Bradleys AMX handeln sollte das Signal
ist klar die Dämme sind nun gebrochen
und die panzerflut aus Washington und
Paris wird wohl auch Leopard 2 in die
Ukraine spielen ja gerade dazu
geschaffen wurden die
hauptkampfpanzersetischer Konstruktion
zu kontern grundsätzlich befinden die
Streitkräfte der Ukraine damit in einem
Prozess immer stärker und schließlich
vollständig auf
nato-standardsysteme umzusatteln damit
wird dann nicht nur ihr qualitativer
Kampfvorteil zu nehmen sondern sie
werden strategisch immer NATO
kompatibler bis sie komplett integriert
werden können auf diese Weise kann die
NATO die Ukraine nach einer russischen
Niederlage vor zukünftigen Aggressionen
Moskau schützen genauso wie die dann
militärisch extrem starke Ukraine Europa
schützen wird auch der Konsens oder die
NATO Mitgliedern dass die Ukraine den
Krieg gewinnen kann und muss wird immer
klarer gewinnen bedeuten natürlich die
Befreiung aller besetzten Gebiete
einschließlich der Grillen ja es hat
eine Weile gedauert bis sich dies alle
vergegenwärtigt haben aber nur wenn all
das sichergestellt wird kann Russland
effektiv daran gehindert werden in
Zukunft weitere Angriffskriege in Europa
zu führen gut das sind die langfristigen
Auswirkungen der aktuellen Entwicklung
aber was steht jetzt kurzfristig an
nun wie im Herbst wurden die russischen
Streitkräfte wie gesagt mit Hilfe
überlegene Aufklärung und Langstrecken
Artillerie Nürnberg gemacht so dass ein
Durchbruch der Frontlinie und
anschließender Durchmarsch möglichst
ohne großen Widerstand und somit ohne
große eigene Verluste erfolgen kann
während es den Russen grundsätzlich eher
um einfach Vorankommen durch brachialen
Einsatz von Mann und Material geht
setzen die Ukraine weiterhin
grundsätzlich auf die Strategie die
eigenen Verluste zu minimieren und die
des Gegners zu maximieren egal ob bei
der Defensive oder Offensive der bisher
sehr wahre Winter hat jedoch zu einer
starken Verkürzung des Zeitfensters
geführt in dem ein winterfeldzug mit
mobilen Panzerfahrzeugen möglich ist
bevor die [ __ ] so früher einsetzt
mehr als 5 bis 8 Wochen werden die
Ukraine nicht haben um die Ernte ihrer
zur wirkungskampagne einzufahren wenn
die ukrainische Armeeführung also zum
Ergebnis kommt dass dies ausreicht und
vor allem die vorhin genannten
strategischen Bedingungen für eine
Winteroffensive gegeben sind wird diese
äußerst heftig und blutig ausfallen und
danach folgt in der nächsten Pizza der
stammsaison weitere Monate lange
zermürbungsphase natürlich werden wir am
Ball bleiben und euch auf dem laufenden
halten vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo
unbedingt mit Glöckchen und wenn ihr
dies erledigt habt sind die Fragen jetzt
erstmal an euch gerichtet was meint ihr
wie sich der Winterkrieg entwickeln wird
und was wird mit Putins und KD
rausgesucht passieren wenn sie den Krieg
weiterhin verlieren glaubt ihr das
Putin gegenüber in jedem Fall loyal
bleiben wird und was wird er wohl tun
wenn sein Ziel Vater Putin stirbt aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen zurücktreten
muss oder vielleicht bei einer Palast
Revolution im Kreml gestürzt wird könnte
der Krieg in der Ukraine den Prozess der
Loslösung von Russland reanimieren oder
werden die Tschechien eines Tages
einfach genug von Kathi rauf haben wie
immer sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
was ja gibt uns mit einem like das mit
meinen Freunden und da ist die gesagt
nicht das aber mit Glück keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mir das heißt dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]